hello everyone this is samir from audio
science review
there was a good comment on one of my
older reviews um
asking if i could point out some real
finds real
hidden jewels that people may not know
about
and so i thought that was a good idea
tons of stuff i review
obviously are similar to each other and
uh
while the performance may differ you
know it's not always something that you
jump up and down
on occasionally though there comes an
obscure device
and it performs a lot better than we
expect or
the value is fantastic so one of those
products i'm about to talk about is in
the class of desktop amplifiers
before i tell you about that let me tell
you how desktop dacs work
in that vast majority of
digital uh analog converters start with
a piece of silicon then a
company makes that specializes making
dac chips
and that dac then has circuits
surrounding it that makes it a complete
box and that's what you buy
so the job there is to not screw up the
performance of those dac chips they're
they're made to perform extremely well
but require precision circuits around
them
and it's not trivial necessarily to
produce great performing
decks with very high resolution and low
noise
on amplification side we haven't had
that we do have modules from company
called
high pick hypex and purify the build
modules that are very high performance
but there's no single chip solution that
you could just go by
and slap it down um there are many many
such silicone dope amplification uh the
applications probably
some kind of bluetooth speaker and these
new smart speakers and what have you
so as you can imagine having absolute
performance is
not a goal there they're you know
they're designed for sound bars and
things and
uh prices everything and and performance
just needs to be good enough
and that's what they ship um
and we thought that was it so if you you
know i've tested a lot of these desktop
uh amplifiers they're cheap fifty eighty
hundred dollars under twenty dollars and
uh
uh you know of the usual connectivity
but you know performance is just not
there
um you know compared to a proper high
five piece of gear
that has changed um with the
in advent of a new silicon that i'll
talk about but let me first show you one
implementation that i
uh that i've measured recently and i
don't know how they pronounce this name
is iema a07
it's amplifier desktop amplifier
it only cost 72 on amazon and it used to
not come with a power supply and i'll
show you later on
that it now does although in some
countries people have ordered it
and didn't get the power supply so you
may want to check the power supply is
not expensive but it adds you know 10 20
to the to the price but they're based on
this uh
texas instruments tpa 3255
uh silicon and if you look in here
it's uh you know that rate of 600 watts
is
i'm not going to do 600 watts mono or
even 315 watts
stereo uh that's you know maybe for a
few milliseconds
but it's designed to be a very high
performance if you see in here
it says you know it's true premium sound
quality
and class d efficiency and
you can tell they're serious when the
first thing they show you on the front
page is
is one of their graphs usually these are
buried all the way in the back
but uh you know they're brave enough to
uh go ahead and show you this as
something that performs really well uh
again claims are for
free a lot of these chip companies will
say these things but uh
uh you know this this is a real deal as
i'll show you
um so as i said for 70 bucks you get a
volume control
uh you get a set of rca inputs instead
of binding posts
these posts are usually very close to
each other and and
hard to uh you know get uh terminate
them but
it's doable even my large banana plugs
managed to get in there
the owner that sent this to me i went
ahead and bought an aftermarket uh
power supply um the one that comes with
it if i can read sideways
is the is this one the uh 32 volt
one five amps uh turns out if you look
at the chip spec
it can go as high as 51 volt input for
maximum power
um if you don't have 51 volts you can't
drive eight home
impedance to max power and then but at
the same time you also need a lot of
current
to drive let's say a forum load and
unfortunately neither one of these
is gonna produce maximum power one of
them will give you more power at eight
ohm one of them will give you more
power out for them but you know to get
one that gives you
max power on both you need a b fair
power supply
uh these are mass market power supplies
that exist so they're dirt cheap
the moment you go outside of this these
you can't get these twenty dollar
fifteen dollar
power supplies you end up buying you
know
power supply cages they're open you may
have to put your own case in there
and by the way this chip's available so
i'm sure there are 50 other people
making
boards out of it and amplifiers
but this one is a real thing that's that
i've tested and so
it's a you know commercial concern and
if you go on audio science review
website you'll see that there's
30 000 posts on on on the topic of this
chip and and this amplifier so
it's got a lot a lot of following in
there um
i went ahead and and uh put this on my
bench and measure it into five watts
that i always do
i run a one kilohertz tone is the center
tone this is desired
and all other uh stuff that you see in
here is undesired
um we see that distortion in one channel
is pretty good
95 db the other one shrinks to 90 db
blue and red are the two channels being
analyzed
it has a lot of ac mains noise that is
coming in
and these switching power supplies tend
to have a capacitor from input to output
to shunt some of the emissions onto the
mains
and that tends to cause this kind of
mains leakage
luckily our threshold of hearing is
somewhere up here so you don't hear this
as hum
but it exists with other power supplies
this could be
nullified if you had a you know more
expensive fancier
power supply but anyway um i set the
gain to 29 db that's a thx
standard so every app that has a volume
control i have to decide to set it to
something so as a standard i adjust them
to be uh the same 29 db of gain if you
don't know what that means that's okay
just know that as
you know somewhat of a standard in the
industry as far as how much
how much the input gets multiplied to
produce an output
the key in here is if you take the noise
and distortion atom up
and take it as a ratio of our original
our
power at the frequency that we want so
you take the power of all of these
versus this one
wanted versus unwanted and you see that
the distortion and noise are 82 decibels
less than our signal
uh you say what that means out of some
like 140 amplifiers i've measured
um the average is 78. so this is 83 so
it's well above
average and it falls in this green area
which i call
sort of the competent area the ones in
blue are untouchable they're
state-of-the-art
but you know for 70 bucks you're not
gonna get up there but to get it down
here is quite an accomplishment there
are a lot of
you know major brands you've heard of
audio video receivers and others that
fall in here falling orange and some
crazy high-end audio
audio file stuff actually lands in red
so this is quite good
most of the time this sign ad will be in
the 60s for these desktop products for
17
amplifier you don't usually get this
because of that unfortunate mains hum
the signal noise ratio is not very good
um
it's it clears 16 bits at full power
which which is
fine just know that from audibility
point of view it's actually a lot better
than this
because again we don't hear 60 hertz um
but it
gets penalized in this signal noise
ratio test where we test
the amplitude of the full power versus
um in this right side versus no power
and at full power at that 5 watts which
is just a little bit of power
still clears 14 and a half bits so not
bad but
clearly not state-of-the-art again
that's a function of that power supply
not because of the chip itself is not
that good
um a measures frequency response
um if all of these class d amplifiers
have to have an output filter to get rid
of the switching frequencies and
they tend to not be flat in in audio
band the high-end ones are but
so this one drops just half 0.7 db so
it's really not
audible and your speaker may be peaking
there at 0.7 tv anyway
so it's not bad um i've measured
crosstalk
and uh i have two references in here one
is state-of-the-art benchmark uh
hb2 uh amplifiers the best amplifier
i've ever tested with respect to
crosstalk
and some other measurements also uh and
then
excuse me one of the worst ones that
i've tested is this uh
lappy lp 2028 it's a 25
amplifier and you can see where that is
so this one lands
in the middle which is fine it's just
you rarely get something better than
this in this class and
again there are a lot of mass-market
amplifiers they're just the same as this
one
um if we go in and measure its power
with forum load uh it shuts down at 77
watts
so this little box that you bought for
70 bucks it puts on nearly 80 watts
both channels driven so it's putting out
160 watts of total power
continuous power which is extremely good
and it's not even clipping
um you know it just shuts down at that
point
and uh you know you could uh you know if
there was more power available it would
keep going and
um i tested it with both power supplies
and as i mentioned with four ohm load
the the higher voltage one that's 48
volts
power supply but only three amps costs
you
uh power in here so you go down to 55
watts
because this test needs current because
the impedance the load that is driving
is low it emphasizes current delivery in
an amplifier
um you see two more references again
this is the benchmark hp2 you can see
how low its distortion goes it just
bottoms out
where my analyzer is nearly minus 120 db
and then so one of the worst ones i've
tested is this nad
t758 audio video receiver
supposedly a mid to high end avr
and it's one of the worst of measured
and you can see this guy up
easily outperforms n80 although many
amplifiers too
and at the end it sort of gets close to
it but for 70 bucks
you know and uh on this thing so
remarkable
um when we go to 8 ohms the rolls
reverse
in that the 48 volt power supply
produces a little bit more of a
fair bit more powers you get 61 watts
and
uh the 32 volt one only gives you 48 so
you really need a 48 volt
5 amp combination unfortunately we have
48 volts and three amps and
32 volt and five amps one has more
current but less voltage and inverse of
that so
uh but you know the most amplifier most
speakers by the way are down in four
ohms they're not
in uh you know eight ohm even though
they specify them at eight home usually
that's a lie
so you're better off with the stock one
that comes with this which is a 32 volt
5 amp
power supply um around the tab
all these tests so far have been at one
kilohertz and but i also test at many
other frequencies so
this test i start sweeping from 15
kilohertz down to 20 hertz
and each one of these shows the power
versus distortion at different levels
um class d amplifiers as a rule
are quite messy by the way an ideal
amplifier would have all of these lines
right on top of each other which means
it doesn't care about frequency
that almost never happens some
amplifiers have come close but usually
that doesn't happen
so usually as frequencies go up uh so
does distortion so this is 15 kilohertz
line over here we can see that
it's gone up uh over here and uh
and then 20 hertz we can see is the word
at best but
it also bottoms out and starts to clip
at 20 hertz
whereas it clipped a lot later so power
delivery at 20 hertz is much lower
why because 20 hertz signals slowly
moves up and down
so the reservoir capacitors we have in
the power supply
runs out of run out of juice and power
delivery uh uh
is reduced so um this is typical again
almost every amplifier test has less
power at 20 hertz
than it does at frequencies above that
that 50 60 hertz and higher
so i can't penalize this one too much
for that
so uh for 70 bucks you get something
that you're not
embarrassed about i mean this is like
they're cheap i can't
if i were in the business of selling you
things i couldn't sell you the case and
the power supply
for 70 bucks uh let alone uh have an
amplifier in it and and uh
um with this level of performance uh on
this thing so
uh that the two things you want to
remember is this um
the tpa 3255 is the is the chip
and the and the name of the company yama
uh maybe i can quickly show you the uh
teardown of it so
bear with me um
uh there we go diy audio
go to tear downs and uh yeah here we go
so this is what's inside of this uh you
actually unfortunately
can't see the uh amplifier chip the
amplifier chip is hiding under this guy
it's a nice uh little heat sink you can
see it sideways over here
uh for the size but it's not gonna be
good enough to
dissipate more power than it already is
it gets pretty warm inside there
and the heatsink is not attached to the
case so it can't
it can't dissipate as well as it could
the case is metal
so if you want to juice this up and some
people have you might want to take it
out of his case and and put a bigger
beefier heat sink on it and needs to be
two or three times bigger
um luckily class d is efficient so you
don't dissipate a ton of power
but uh still um usually i find dirt
cheap crappy
third-rate uh capacitors in these things
and these capacitors sit right next to
the heatsink which means they're gonna
cook
and that's the last thing electrolytic
capacitor likes to have is having
heat source to it because that
electrolytic
electrolyte that's in there dries out
and once it dries out you
don't have a capacitor anymore per se
and impedance goes up
it then it blows itself up so life goes
down
so you usually want the highest grade
capacitors you can get and the japanese
companies own that market right now
panasonic and chicon and
and so forth i was surprised this
actually says nichikon in it i mean you
could buy
american products or even iron products
and find that they
have third grade uh chinese uh korean or
taiwanese capacitors in them
i i don't know if this is real or is
fake or
or what um people
nobody could tell whether it was fake
people thought maybe it is real if
that's the case that's a miracle you
know we have high quality capacitors
to go with that uh what's in there um
the bottom of it has nothing in it which
is you know good from cost production
point of view
it's to put everything on one side uh
little smudges in here from
you know cleaning it or not cleaning it
so yeah
seventy dollars don't be too picky
you're not gonna
look at this every day but uh otherwise
it looks clean i mean i don't see any
issues
did a thermal analysis of it driving 20
watts for six minutes you can see
it's up to 57 degrees c unfortunately
this temperature is fictitious what we
care about is the junction temperature
that's what determines when that chip is
going to destroy itself
in this case has thermal protection
anyways it'll just shut down
before it gets destroyed but from
longevity
point of view it's nice to cool it um so
i did the math in here at 90 efficiency
it's producing eight watts eight watts
is
fair amount of heat i mean that's
non-trivial amount of heat and
you got to get it out of there so anyway
um you know i'm usually picky when i do
these tear downs i find
every little things wrong with this
stuff i point them out and uh
i couldn't so it's actually quite good
for what it is i mean this is
it's just amazing you see the parts of
you know they have these uh
op amps in here they're socketed and
people like to go screw around with
those things replace them
i've done tests of those that don't do
you any good
maybe i'll cover that in another review
on this thing you know somebody had to
sit there manually solder these things
and package them and send them to you
anyway
um hopefully this was something
educational
if you need a desktop amplifier if you
need an amplifier and a garage
you need one in the bedroom someplace uh
this would be a good choice there's no
remote control so maybe you can get a
dac that has a remote control and
and drive it with that um but otherwise
if
you know if you have it on a desk where
you can turn the volume up and down put
a couple of passive speakers and
uh you have a ton of power i mean 780
watts
is nothing to laugh at them you can
drive you know
sized tower speakers and uh for the cost
of going to mcdonald's two or three
times
uh you have yourself a you know what
seems to be a quality uh
uh amplifier and uh join the discussion
audio signs review uh
they're just incredible number of
enthusiasts talking about
juice these things up who makes the best
one and what to do with them just
generically around the tpa part but also
the uh
this amplifier specifically uh the
company
is active on the website and they're
sending me some other future products
they have for testing
i have no commercial relationship with
them whatsoever with them or any other
company so
i just go buy some company makes good
stuff i
give credit where it's due okay
hopefully you found this useful and a
break from our
rest of the videos that we've been doing
okay see you in a future video bye-bye